This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all know what it feels like to work on a great team. People like and trust one another. Team mates communicate with each other. Meetings are crisp and effective. At the end of the day, things just get done. We've all been on bad teams too. Here, interminable meetings become a substitute
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都知道在优秀的团队中工作是什么感觉。成员们彼此喜欢并相互信任。队友之间沟通顺畅。会议简洁高效。一天结束时，事情总能圆满完成。我们也都在糟糕的团队中待过。在那种环境下，没完没了的会议成了
for doing actual work. People undermine and undercut one another. Productivity is low and morale even lower. There is something mysterious about great teams. We know what they are when we see them, but how exactly do they come together? Is there a way to figure out the secret sauce of great teams and build teams based on this recipe? Today we take a deep dive into the science of teamwork. We'll explore one of the most common errors
实际工作的替代品。人们互相拆台、互相掣肘。生产力低下，士气更是低落。优秀的团队身上有一种神秘感。我们一眼就能认出它们，但它们究竟是如何形成的呢？有没有办法找出优秀团队的“秘方”，并以此为基础组建团队？今天，我们将深入探讨团队合作的科学。我们将探索最常见的错误之一，
we make in constructing teams and what effective teams do in order to punch far above their weight. and what effective teams do in order to punch far above their weight. How to build great teams this week on Hidden Brain. There are times in our lives when we become lost in the things we do. Time vanishes. Minutes pass then hours. We don't notice that the sun has set or that we forgot to eat lunch. Psychologists sometimes call this a state of flow. Now, flow is supposed to be an individual state, but the same thing sometimes happens on
即我们在组建团队时所犯的错误，以及高效团队如何做到远超预期的表现。如何组建优秀的团队，本周《隐藏的大脑》为您揭晓。生活中，我们有时会沉浸在所做的事情中，以至于迷失自我。时间消失了。几分钟过去了，接着是几小时。我们没有注意到太阳已经落山，或者忘记了吃午饭。心理学家有时称之为“心流”状态。心流通常被认为是一种个人状态，但同样的事情有时也会发生在
effective teams. We feel in sync with other members of our group, tasks get done almost effortlessly. At Carnegie Mellon University, psychologist Anita Williams-Woully studies the science of teamwork. She has explored not only why some teams click, but why others don't. It turns out you can learn a lot by observing teams where people are constantly at loggerheads. Anita Woolly, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi thanks for having me. Anita, I understand you grew up in a small town in Maine and at the age of 14 you got a job waiting tables at a local restaurant and it gave you an early glimpse into the nature of teams.
高效的团队中。我们感到与团队其他成员步调一致，任务几乎毫不费力地就完成了。在卡内基梅隆大学，心理学家安妮塔·威廉姆斯·伍利研究团队合作的科学。她不仅探索了为什么有些团队能产生共鸣，还研究了为什么有些团队不能。事实证明，通过观察那些人们总是争吵不休的团队，你可以学到很多。安妮塔·伍利，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨，谢谢你邀请我。安妮塔，我听说你在缅因州的一个小镇长大，14岁时在当地一家餐馆做服务员，那次经历让你很早就窥见了团队的本质。
What were your co-workers like? Oh, well, it was definitely an interesting employment situation. I'd had other jobs before this, but was really excited to be a waitress. There were a variety of people, some of whom were older. I'd been working at the restaurant longer, and then a couple teenagers like me, and the old timers sometimes were a bit annoyed by some of the younger ones, maybe a little threatened, you know, that we wouldn't come in and take their tips or whatever,
你的同事们是什么样的？哦，那确实是一个有趣的就业环境。在那之前我做过其他工作，但能当服务员让我非常兴奋。那里有各种各样的人，有些人年纪较大。我在那家餐馆工作的时间比他们长，还有几个像我一样的青少年。老员工有时会对一些年轻人感到恼火，甚至可能感到一点威胁，你知道，担心我们抢了他们的小费之类的，
and so it could be a little challenging to work with them and get along. She quickly learned a tiptoe around one coworker in particular. Yeah, so she'd been there the longest and she was just somebody who I think was easily frustrated and she just would wanna, either tell us what to do or blame us for problems
所以和他们共事并相处融洽可能会有点挑战。她很快学会了在某位特定同事面前小心翼翼。是的，她在那里待的时间最长，我觉得她是一个很容易感到沮丧的人，她总是想要么告诉我们该做什么，要么把问题归咎于我们，
or find ways to point out the problems or mistakes that we were making as a way, maybe of keeping us in our place. I need to remember one day at work when things came to a boil. So New Year's Eve, lots of people, lots of different things happening. Everybody needs help at some point. She had a way of sort of barking at you if she needed you to do something, regardless of what you might be doing.
或者想方设法指出我们犯的错误，以此作为一种让我们安分守己的方式。我记得有一天在工作中，事情到了爆发的边缘。那是除夕夜，人很多，各种事情都在发生。每个人在某个时刻都需要帮助。如果她需要你做什么，她有一种对你大吼大叫的习惯，不管你当时在忙什么。
And so one of the things she barked at me about was she wanted me to make drinks for her table. At that restaurant, the waitresses made the drinks. And I had no idea how to make drinks. I had a few recipes in my pocket. And I didn't really know what the drink was. She wanted me to make, but I didn't want to ask her because I knew that was just going to be really negative to have her yelling at me in the middle of the restaurant. So I just kind of made it up. I was like, okay, that kind of
所以她对我大吼大叫的一件事是，她想让我为她的桌子调酒。在那家餐馆，服务员负责调酒。但我根本不知道怎么调酒。我口袋里有几张配方。我真的不知道她想让我调什么酒，但我不想问她，因为我知道在餐馆中间被她大吼大叫会非常糟糕。所以我只好胡乱调了一杯。我想，好吧，这听起来像是……
sounds like this. And apparently it was terrible. You know, it was worse than if I just asked her, but there were lots of episodes like that with her because of just, you know, how aversive or difficult it was to really interact with her. And of course, when you made the drinks, the way that you thought the drinks should be made, when you just basically essentially made it up, the customers probably said, this might not be a restaurant we want to come back to,
结果显然糟透了。你知道，这比我直接问她还要糟糕。因为她那种令人厌恶或难以相处的性格，我和她之间发生过很多类似的事情。当然，当你按照自己认为应该调配的方式去调酒，当你基本上是胡乱调配时，顾客可能会说，这可能不是我们想再来的餐馆，
whether or not they actually said anything aloud. That's right, I mean, in a small town, especially is a really big problem. And I think you know if a customer is drinking something that tastes really strange, you know they might even wonder about the safety of the things that were serving them, let alone the quality. So Anita after you graduated high school you went on to college on an ROTC scholarship. This is a scholarship where the government helps pay for your education and you commit to serving in the military for a length of time after you graduate.
不管他们是否真的说出口。没错，尤其是在小镇上，这是一个非常大的问题。我想你知道，如果顾客喝的东西味道非常奇怪，他们甚至可能会怀疑我们供应的东西的安全性，更不用说质量了。那么安妮塔，高中毕业后，你凭借预备役军官训练团（ROTC）的奖学金上了大学。这是一种政府资助你教育的奖学金，你承诺毕业后在军队服役一段时间。
You attended a training camp at Fort Bragg in North Carolina that gave you another insight into the nature of teamwork. What was it like to be a female cadet? It was challenging in ROTC because everything was designed with men in mind. So the clothing, for example, our uniforms were all designed for men, so boots were wide, pants didn't have wastes, you know, that kind of thing. And also, I was often the only or one of only a few female cadets. Also, the activities were designed for people who have more upper body strength or who
你在北卡罗来纳州的布拉格堡参加了训练营，这让你对团队合作的本质有了另一种洞察。作为一名女性学员是什么感觉？在ROTC中这很有挑战性，因为一切都是为男性设计的。例如服装，我们的制服都是为男性设计的，所以靴子很宽，裤子没有腰身，你知道，就是那种情况。而且，我通常是唯一的或仅有的几名女性学员之一。此外，这些活动也是为那些拥有更多上半身力量或拥有
have certain physical attributes. I understand that there was a training exercise where a squad had to essentially get from point A to point B. And this was had to be done in a limited amount of time with everyone carrying a lot of equipment. Give me a sense of how your team handle that challenge and what happened. Yeah, so this exercise, they call them stragg lanes, where a group of maybe 10 or so people,
特定身体素质的人设计的。我听说有一个训练练习，一个小队必须从A点移动到B点。这必须在有限的时间内完成，而且每个人都要携带大量装备。请告诉我你的团队是如何应对这一挑战的，以及发生了什么。是的，这个练习他们称之为“障碍跑”，大约10个人一组，
you have different obstacles. And there was a male cadet who was in charge. He had to lead us through this thing to get everything over this obstacle. And he just had assumed that okay, these couple of females we have, they're not going to be any use. We just have to work around them. So I'm just going to lay it out and get these other guys to do it and we'll you know, work around them, essentially. Not really wanting to listen to any input or ideas from anybody and just thinking he had
你要面对不同的障碍。当时有一名男性学员负责。他必须带领我们越过这个障碍。他只是想当然地认为，好吧，我们这几个女性成员没什么用。我们只要绕过她们就行了。所以我只要安排好，让其他男生来做，我们基本上就绕过她们。他真的不想听取任何人的意见或想法，只是认为他必须
to decide it all himself. And what happened? Did it work? It was a disaster. Because as it turns out, I mean, there were things that the women could have done to help, as well as things the guys couldn't do that he was assuming they could do. And so we had people, you know, equipment that couldn't get over the wall. People got left behind, time ran out.
自己决定一切。结果怎么样？成功了吗？那是一场灾难。因为事实证明，有些事情女性本可以帮忙，而有些男生以为能做到的事情他们却做不到。所以我们有人的装备没能越过墙，有人掉队了，时间也用完了。
It was, yeah, it was a pretty big disaster. If it had been a real situation, we probably all would have died. When she was in college Anita had taken a class with a professor named Richard Hackman. He was a researcher who studied teams. Richard Hackman really introduced a lot of important insights about teams but the thing that was striking to me, related to the fact that there were a lot of components of teamwork that didn't have so much to do with what the people knew, as much as the ways that they were coordinating their inputs together. And he had lots and lots of examples in his course that I found totally fascinating of, you know, brilliant people put together to fly an airplane to, you know, perform in an orchestra. I mean, he studied a lot of different
是的，那真是一场相当大的灾难。如果是在真实情况下，我们可能都死了。在大学时，安妮塔上过一位名叫理查德·哈克曼的教授的课。他是一位研究团队的研究员。理查德·哈克曼确实引入了许多关于团队的重要见解，但让我印象深刻的是，团队合作的许多组成部分与人们知道什么关系不大，更多的是与他们如何协调彼此的投入有关。他在课程中举了大量让我觉得非常着迷的例子，比如，把聪明人聚在一起驾驶飞机，或者在管弦乐队中表演。我的意思是，他研究了许多不同的
interesting situations where they're very talented people, but failures in their collaboration and in their teamwork in ways that you wouldn't expect. And I'm imagining this is sort of, this must have run counter, not just your assumptions, but to a lot of other students in the class. Because again, the idea that you put a lot of brilliant people together and you get a brilliant team that seems so intuitive.
有趣的情况，那里有非常有才华的人，但他们的协作和团队合作却出现了意想不到的失败。我想这一定不仅违背了你的假设，也违背了班上许多其他学生的假设。因为再次强调，把许多聪明人聚在一起就能得到一个优秀团队的想法，似乎非常直观。
Absolutely. And also another piece of it that was enlightening was the fact that it's not all about the leader. And I think especially younger people have the idea, at least at the time, and certainly in ROTC, that the leader makes all the difference. If the leader knows what's going on or knows what to do, then everything else will be fine. Whereas Richard also had a lot of examples showing that it wasn't just about the leader. You really needed all the team members to be contributing and actively collaborating for things to come together. When it comes to building great teams, many of us leap to understandable assumptions. Get the smartest, most talented people together, put them under the leadership of an effective
绝对是这样。另一个具有启发性的部分是，这并不完全取决于领导者。我认为，尤其是年轻人，至少在当时，当然在ROTC中，都有这样一种想法：领导者决定一切。如果领导者知道发生了什么或知道该做什么，那么其他一切都会好起来。而理查德也有很多例子表明，这不仅仅是关于领导者。你确实需要所有团队成员都做出贡献并积极协作，事情才能成功。在组建优秀团队时，我们许多人会跳向一些可以理解的假设。把最聪明、最有才华的人聚在一起，让他们在一位高效的
leader and you build a great team. But the research that Anita was studying challenged that conventional wisdom. When we come back, the errors we all make in building teams can cost us on the sports field and in office settings. They can also have life and death consequences. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan.
领导者的带领下工作，你就能组建一个优秀的团队。但安妮塔研究的成果挑战了这种传统智慧。稍后回来，我们在组建团队时所犯的错误可能会让我们在运动场和办公环境中付出代价。它们也可能带来生死攸关的后果。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
It seems like simple arithmetic. If people are ranked on a scale of 1 to 10 and you build a team of tens, you should have a standout team. Each individual is smart. When you assemble a bunch of superstars, you should get a superstar team. Unfortunately, human behavior is more complicated than that. At Carnegie Mellon University, psychologist Anita Wolley has studied why arithmetic is not always a good guide to psychology.
这看起来像是简单的算术。如果人们按1到10的等级评分，而你组建了一个由10分选手组成的团队，你应该会有一个出色的团队。每个人都很聪明。当你聚集了一群超级明星时，你应该会得到一个超级明星团队。不幸的是，人类行为比这复杂得多。在卡内基梅隆大学，心理学家安妮塔·伍利研究了为什么算术并不总是心理学的良好指南。
Anita, we often see that teams have everything going for them. They're filled with brilliant people who know each other well, they're motivated to succeed, but very often they don't, and at a national level, this can sometimes have catastrophic consequences. Tell me about the team of the best and the brightest that President John F. Kennedy put together in the 1960s. So Kennedy put together a group of people who he knew, he trusted, they were really accomplished.
安妮塔，我们经常看到团队拥有所有有利条件。他们充满了彼此熟悉、才华横溢的人，他们有成功的动力，但往往他们却失败了。在国家层面，这有时会产生灾难性的后果。跟我说说约翰·F·肯尼迪总统在20世纪60年代组建的那支由最优秀、最聪明的人组成的团队吧。肯尼迪组建了一群他认识、信任的人，他们确实非常有成就。
People like Robert Kennedy, of course. There was Arthur Sleshinger. There was Robert McNamara. People that we heard about a lot before and after in terms of their individual accomplishments and definitely seemed to be set up to work together well and advising him as this cabinet. But this team of superstars ended up making a number of very serious mistakes.
比如罗伯特·肯尼迪，当然还有亚瑟·施莱辛格，还有罗伯特·麦克纳马拉。这些人我们在他们个人成就方面听过很多，他们看起来确实非常适合在一起工作，并作为内阁成员为他提供建议。但这个超级明星团队最终犯下了一系列非常严重的错误。
One was the botched invasion of Cuba on April 17, 1961. The invading army was a group of Cuban exiles trained by the CIA. Their goal was to overthrow President Fidel Castro and his revolutionary government. Anita says it's a classic example of what can happen when a lot of smart people on a team have the same biases and blind spots. They had a plan to land at the Bay of Pigs and move into the country and displace his government. And they thought the Cuban people would be aligned with that and supportive of that and be happy to see the Americans come.
其中之一就是1961年4月17日拙劣的入侵古巴行动。入侵军队是一群由中央情报局训练的古巴流亡者。他们的目标是推翻菲德尔·卡斯特罗总统及其革命政府。安妮塔说，这是一个经典的例子，说明当团队中许多聪明人拥有相同的偏见和盲点时会发生什么。他们计划在猪湾登陆，进入该国并取代他的政府。他们认为古巴人民会与此保持一致并支持这一点，会很高兴看到美国人到来。
But there were a lot of indicators to suggest that maybe they were overlooking some opposition, some opinions, even within Cuba that wouldn't necessarily see this as a great thing. But these weren't really raised in the discussions, or not enough to cause the president to reconsider his plan. The attack was supposed to be secret, but unbeknownst to the White House, the Cuban government learned about it ahead of time and prepared accordingly. The Cuban military quickly surrounded the invaders, taking most of them prisoner. Now all of a sudden, Fidel could even make a case for why the U.S. was actually the enemy. And so they kind of went into it with some assumptions about how it would be received and how
但有很多迹象表明，他们可能忽略了一些反对意见，甚至在古巴内部也有一些意见并不一定认为这是一件好事。但这些在讨论中并没有真正被提出来，或者不足以促使总统重新考虑他的计划。这次袭击本应是秘密的，但白宫不知道的是，古巴政府提前得知了消息并做了相应的准备。古巴军队迅速包围了入侵者，俘虏了他们中的大多数人。现在，菲德尔甚至可以证明为什么美国实际上是敌人。所以他们带着一些关于它将如何被接受以及它将如何
successful it would be without really considering the opposition in assumptions about how it would be received and how successful it would be without really considering the opposition in the ways that it might be counterproductive. So two or three decades later, the United States faced another disaster, the explosion of the space shuttle Challenger. The physicist Richard Feynman was appointed to investigate what happened. He concluded that while rank and file engineers were raising questions about the missions, their managers, under pressure from Congress to show results, didn't listen. It's another example of a team composed of very brilliant people. I mean, in this case, literally rocket scientists, and they're failing to coordinate and
成功的假设进入了行动，而没有真正考虑反对意见，以及它可能适得其反的方式。因此，二三十年后，美国面临了另一场灾难，挑战者号航天飞机的爆炸。物理学家理查德·费曼被任命调查发生了什么。他得出的结论是，虽然普通工程师对任务提出了质疑，但他们的经理在国会要求展示成果的压力下，并没有听取意见。这是另一个由非常聪明的人组成的团队的例子。我的意思是，在这种情况下，他们确实是火箭科学家，但他们未能协调和
work well together as a team leading to a major disaster. So the pressures they were operating under in that case, there was a lot of pressure for them to move ahead, with a launch. It had been delayed several times. The public was calling into question the amount of money being spent on the space program.
作为一个团队良好合作，导致了一场重大灾难。所以他们在那种情况下承受的压力，他们面临着很大的压力要推进发射。它已经被推迟了好几次。公众质疑在太空计划上花费的金额。
And so they were very motivated to find a way to move forward, to not delay again, and were then motivated to discount any objections that were being raised, which we do know in that case, there were some concerns being voiced. They weren't being voiced by somebody who was very senior in status in the group, but we know now that those concerns were very valid and what was being described, in fact, did happen.
所以他们非常有动力找到前进的方法，不再推迟，因此有动力去忽视任何被提出的反对意见，我们确实知道在那种情况下，有一些担忧被表达出来。这些担忧并不是由团队中地位很高的人提出的，但我们现在知道这些担忧是非常有效的，而且所描述的情况实际上确实发生了。
I understand that you yourself were involved in understanding how the terrorist attacks of 911 occurred and how to prevent similar attacks from taking place after 9-11. With your mentor Richard Hackman, you took part in something called project looking glass where groups of scientists pretended to be terrorists and members of the US intelligence services tried to foil attacks. How did these games unfold Anita? Well, they were fascinating exercises where we would convene two teams to basically work against each other in some ways. Many times what these exercises would focus on would be
我了解到你本人也参与了了解9/11恐怖袭击是如何发生的，以及如何在9/11之后防止类似袭击发生的工作。你和你的导师理查德·哈克曼一起参加了一个名为“窥镜计划”（Project Looking Glass）的项目，科学家小组假装成恐怖分子，而美国情报部门的成员则试图阻止袭击。这些游戏是如何展开的，安妮塔？嗯，它们是非常迷人的练习，我们会召集两个团队，在某些方面基本上让他们相互对抗。很多时候，这些练习的重点是
a threat from the past. Sometimes we would know how it had panned out sometimes not. And in some cases, the personnel were kind of adopting the goals and the motivations of the folks that might be trying to carry out an attack while others would be trying to then figure out and prevent the attack from taking place. And very different dynamics would develop in the two groups on the basis of their role, which I think itself was quite insightful to notice how that happened as a function of what they were trying to do. Was it the case that in fact, the terrorists regularly beat the spies?
过去的威胁。有时我们会知道它是如何发展的，有时则不知道。在某些情况下，人员会采用那些可能试图实施袭击的人的目标和动机，而其他人则会试图找出并防止袭击发生。两个小组会根据他们的角色发展出非常不同的动态，我认为注意到这一点本身就很有洞察力，因为这是他们试图做的事情的函数。事实是恐怖分子经常打败间谍吗？
Yes, and some would say, that could be expected, right? You have the benefit of surprise when you're on the offense, but it was also true that taking that perspective on the situation, let them to just really think creatively in some ways, and really focus on what they were trying to carry out and make really good use of the opportunities that they saw,
是的，有些人会说，这是可以预料的，对吧？当你处于进攻方时，你拥有突袭的优势，但同样真实的是，从那种角度看待局势，让他们在某些方面真正地进行创造性思考，并真正专注于他们试图执行的任务，并充分利用他们看到的各种机会，
and so the dynamic was much more creative and exciting in those teams, and they did regularly come up with things that the other team didn't detect or make plans to prevent. One of the things that you were trying to do with this project looking glass in ETA was you were trying to address essentially a shortcoming that had been identified among US intelligence agencies, which is that it seemed to be the case that different aspects of the US intelligence agency network had information about the 9-11 attacks, but they didn't share this information in a way that would be useful for other parts of the system. Talk a little bit about this idea that you were trying to solve. It wasn't just a question of
所以这些团队中的动态要创造性得多，也令人兴奋得多，他们确实经常想出对方团队没有察觉或没有计划预防的事情。安妮塔，你在“窥镜计划”中试图做的一件事是，你试图解决美国情报机构中发现的一个本质上的缺陷，即美国情报机构网络的不同方面似乎掌握着关于9/11袭击的信息，但他们并没有以对系统其他部分有用的方式共享这些信息。谈谈你试图解决的这个想法。这不仅仅是一个
getting the information, but it was also a question of, is the information getting to where it needs to get? Yeah, absolutely. So the 9-11 commission that took place for quite some time after the attacks, one of the major conclusions was that there was a failure of collaboration. They didn't connect the dots. You know, as the cliché came came to be known and people in different agencies and different pockets of the broader intelligence community, either not sharing the information or not reaching out to the right people to make sure they had the information
获取信息的问题，也是一个信息是否传达到位的问题？是的，绝对是。9/11委员会在袭击发生后进行了很长一段时间的调查，其中一个主要结论是协作失败。他们没有把点连起来。你知道，正如后来成为陈词滥调的那样，不同机构和更广泛情报界不同部门的人，要么没有共享信息，要么没有联系合适的人以确保他们掌握了信息，
or realize the implications of the information that they had. And so, you know, hindsight is always 2020 as they say, but even moving forward, it was clear that there was some real problems and they were multifaceted, keeping people from being able to integrate the different pieces in the ways that they needed to. And I understand that you did some work at the micro level sort of looking at individual teams,
或者意识到他们所掌握信息的含义。所以，你知道，正如人们所说，事后诸葛亮总是很准，但即使展望未来，也很清楚存在一些真正的问题，而且它们是多方面的，阻碍了人们以他们需要的方式整合不同部分的能力。我了解到你在微观层面做了一些工作，观察了个人团队、
counterterrorism, task forces, the defense intelligence agency. And sometimes even at the level of individual teams, individual meetings, you were spotting some of the same problems that were manifesting themselves at the much larger level. That's right. When we brought together some of these task forces, for example, it really was a microcosm of
反恐特遣部队、国防情报局。有时甚至在个人团队、个人会议的层面，你也会发现一些在更大层面表现出来的同样问题。没错。当我们召集其中一些特遣部队时，例如，它确实是
the larger community. People came in, they were very closely identified with their own home agency. Many of them had spent their careers there. They had perceptions of the other people based on what agency they were from. In some cases, some of these are military or have other affiliations, they literally wear their identity, you know, on their on their shirt, you know, making it very clear how they're different from the other other folks. And so some of the usual areas of focus, goals, priorities of their home agency would override things that would make more sense
整个社区的缩影。人们进来时，他们与自己的母机构有着非常紧密的认同感。他们中的许多人在那里度过了职业生涯。他们基于自己来自哪个机构而对其他人产生看法。在某些情况下，其中一些是军队或有其他隶属关系，他们实际上把自己的身份穿在衬衫上，你知道，这使得他们与其他人有何不同变得非常清楚。因此，他们母机构的一些通常关注的领域、目标、优先事项会凌驾于那些更有意义的事情之上，
if they were really focusing on their work with the team. So around 15 years ago Anita, you set out to solve the mystery of why some teams work and some teams don't, and you brought people into your lab and organized them into teams and gave them a series of tests. And in some ways this was like an IQ test except it was an IQ test for teamwork. Could you explain what you did? So when we give individuals an intelligence test and of course there are a variety of different ones out there now. Essentially we give them a sample of problems that tap into maybe a few different processes that capture a basic capability.
如果他们真的专注于与团队的工作的话。所以大约15年前，安妮塔，你开始着手解开为什么有些团队有效而有些团队无效的谜团，你把人们带进你的实验室，把他们组织成团队，并给他们进行了一系列测试。在某些方面，这就像智商测试，只不过是团队合作的智商测试。你能解释一下你做了什么吗？当我们给个人进行智力测试时，当然现在外面有各种各样的测试。本质上，我们给他们一系列问题，这些问题触及可能捕捉到基本能力的几种不同过程。
And together can represent the capability of the individual. And here, in thinking about it with teamwork, what we wanted to do was give the team a set of team-based tasks or problems, so things they had to work together to solve, but that would require them to work together in different ways, to capture fundamentally different processes, and things that you wouldn't necessarily assume that the same team would be good at. So, you know, very mathematical, kinds of problems alongside very visual, creative kinds of problems or verbally oriented problems or things that required precision and accuracy and speed
加在一起可以代表个人的能力。在这里，在考虑团队合作时，我们想做的是给团队一套基于团队的任务或问题，也就是说，他们必须共同努力解决的事情，但这需要他们以不同的方式合作，以捕捉根本上不同的过程，而且你未必会认为同一个团队会擅长所有这些。所以，你知道，非常数学化的问题，伴随着非常视觉化、创造性的问题，或者语言导向的问题，或者需要精确度、准确性和速度的事情，
to kind of get at all of these different ways that a team would have to combine their inputs to successfully solve a problem. So one of the things that you drew from these exercises was that just as we think about individuals having an intelligence quotient or an IQ, you could also think of groups having an IQ. This is a bit of a mind-bending idea because of course groups don't share a single brain, but explain what you meant by this and what you found in this study, Anita. We definitely were initially inspired by some of these ideas from individual intelligence, which, abstractly speaking, you could say is the notion that the human brain is a system.
以触及团队必须结合他们的投入来成功解决问题的所有这些不同方式。所以你从这些练习中得出的结论之一是，就像我们认为个人拥有智商（IQ）一样，你也可以认为群体拥有智商。这是一个有点令人费解的想法，因为当然群体没有共享一个大脑，但请解释一下你的意思以及你在研究中发现了什么，安妮塔。我们最初确实受到了一些来自个人智力想法的启发，抽象地说，你可以说这是人类大脑是一个系统的概念。
And intelligence is characterizing how, well, that system functions. And so then we started to think more about what does that mean? How would you capture that? It does that exist, actually, because at the time when even teams researchers thought about intelligence and teams, it was as a function of the intelligence of the individual members. So this idea that there would be a capability of the combination of people working together that was separate from the individual intelligence of members. So this idea that there would be a capability of the combination of people working together that was separate from the individual intelligence of members. That was
而智力是表征该系统功能好坏的特征。所以我们开始更多地思考这意味着什么。你将如何捕捉它？它真的存在吗，因为当时即使是团队研究人员思考团队智力时，也是将其视为个人成员智力的函数。所以，存在一种独立于成员个人智力之外的、人们共同工作组合的能力，这种想法……这
not really an idea that had been tested. So researchers who study intelligence at the individual level have long noticed that you know a kid who does well in math will often do well in history and often do well in languages and they've made the case for something called general intelligence, a kind of capacity that allows you to perform well in very different tasks. In some ways, you were trying to measure the general intelligence of groups. Yeah, that was kind of the initial hypothesis, if you will, because based on what we knew from the research at the time, we had a lot of different studies looking at how does a group interact to be creative versus how does a group interact to be very accurate
并不是一个真正被测试过的想法。所以研究个人智力的研究人员早就注意到，你知道，一个数学好的孩子通常在历史和语言方面也会表现出色，他们提出了所谓的“一般智力”（General Intelligence），这是一种让你在非常不同的任务中表现出色的能力。在某些方面，你是在试图衡量群体的“一般智力”。是的，如果可以的话，那是最初的假设，因为基于我们当时从研究中了解到的情况，我们有很多不同的研究观察群体如何互动以变得有创造力，以及群体如何互动以变得非常准确、
and precise and efficient. And the ways that teams would interact to do both of those things well look very different and suggested that maybe you wouldn't have the same team doing both of those kinds of things or expect them to do equally well at both of those kinds of things. And so we were really testing a hypothesis
精确和高效。团队为了做好这两件事而进行的互动方式看起来非常不同，这表明也许你不会有同一个团队同时做好这两种事情，或者期望他们在两种事情上都表现得同样出色。所以我们确实是在测试一个假设，
that perhaps there is a consistent ability to work together that would characterize a team even across those very different kinds of tasks. Did you find that in fact some groups are consistently effective while other groups are consistently ineffective? Yes, yes we did. And that was really the fundamental hypothesis that we were seeking to test, that there
即也许存在一种持续的合作能力，即使在那些非常不同的任务中也能表征一个团队。你是否发现实际上有些群体始终有效，而另一些群体始终无效？是的，是的，我们发现了。这确实是我们试图测试的基本假设，即
was this consistent ability of certain teams that, you know, work well across all of these different task types. And of course, then, there were teams that did not work well across all of the task types. And of course, what this then suggests is that they must be something that is actually either undermining or supercharging the effectiveness of different teams. And the search was presumably on now to determine what it was exactly that made teams so effective. And of course, one theory that we've looked at before is that effective teams are filled with people who have high IQs. This is, of course, our commonly held belief. Did that hold up to scrutiny?
某些团队确实存在这种持续的能力，你知道，在所有这些不同类型的任务中都能表现良好。当然，也有一些团队在所有任务类型中表现不佳。当然，这随后表明，一定有什么东西实际上在削弱或增强不同团队的有效性。现在搜索的重点大概是确定究竟是什么让团队如此有效。当然，我们之前看过的一个理论是，高效的团队充满了高智商的人。这当然是我们普遍持有的信念。这经得起推敲吗？
Even though we had a ninkling that it wouldn't be all about individual intelligence, we thought that there would be a fairly sizable role for individual ability to play. So we were surprised to see that individual intelligence didn't have as much of a relationship with the collective intelligence of the team as we, as even we kind of expected it would So if it's not intelligence people might say well, maybe it was the personality traits of the individuals in the group Is it possible that the personality traits determine how successful a group was the general intelligence of the group? We didn't really see a consistent, strong relationship with any particular personality traits.
尽管我们隐约感觉到这并不完全取决于个人智力，但我们认为个人能力会发挥相当大的作用。所以我们很惊讶地看到，个人智力与团队集体智力之间的关系并不像我们预期的那样密切。所以如果不是智力，人们可能会说，好吧，也许是群体中个人的性格特征。性格特征是否决定了群体的成功程度，即群体的“一般智力”？我们并没有真正看到与任何特定性格特征的一致、强烈的关系。
Sometimes the problematic personality traits like neuroticism would show up as something that was a negative correlate of collective intelligence, but often it wasn't a very strong relationship and it wasn't very consistent across our studies. Anita, sometimes when we are on successful teams, we often feel like we're all rowing strong relationship and it wasn't very consistent across our studies. Anita, sometimes when we are on successful teams, we often feel like we're all rowing in the same direction. And in some ways you examine this question. Does the feeling that we have cohesion with others make for better teams?
有时像神经质这样有问题的性格特征会表现为与集体智力负相关，但通常它并不是一种非常强烈的关系，而且在我们的研究中也不是非常一致。安妮塔，有时当我们身处成功的团队时，我们经常感觉我们都在朝着同一个方向划桨。在某些方面，你审视了这个问题。我们与他人产生凝聚力的感觉是否会造就更好的团队？
So it turns out that was another surprise and continues to be surprising actually. Some of the other usual suspects and looking at teamwork would be things like cohesion, satisfaction, liking, or even self-report motivation, how motivated are you to work hard. The cohesion went in particular, it was very interesting because,
事实证明，这是另一个惊喜，而且实际上仍然令人惊讶。在审视团队合作时，其他一些通常的怀疑对象会是凝聚力、满意度、好感度，甚至是自我报告的动机，即你努力工作的动力有多大。凝聚力尤其令人感兴趣，因为
given my background in ROTC, the military talked a lot about cohesion, unit cohesion as being a main driver. And we found no correlation with collective intelligence and we still don't. So when we ask people about, you know, how satisfied are you in with your experience in the group, how much would you want to come back and work with this group again? Or would you want to spend time with these people socially? I mean, there are a variety of ways that psychologists get at this notion of groupiness, if you will. We did not see any correlation with collective
鉴于我在ROTC的背景，军队谈论了很多关于凝聚力、单位凝聚力作为主要驱动因素。我们发现它与集体智力没有相关性，现在仍然没有。所以当我们问人们，你知道，你对在团队中的体验有多满意，你有多想回来再次与这个团队合作？或者你想在社交上与这些人共度时光吗？我的意思是，心理学家有各种各样的方法来触及这种“群体感”（groupiness），如果可以这样称呼的话。我们没有看到它与集体
intelligence. So there were certainly some teams in our studies and some teams in our studies and some teams in the world where members enjoy one another and they work well together. But that's not always the case. And certainly there can be people, groups that work together very well and they respect each other, but they're not interested in hanging out beyond what they're doing and they're work together. And I've certainly been in groups where we're all very friendly and like to hang out
智力有任何相关性。所以我们的研究中以及世界上肯定有一些团队，成员们彼此喜欢，他们合作得很好。但这并不总是事实。当然，也可能存在合作得非常好、彼此尊重的群体，但他们对在工作之外进行社交并不感兴趣。我当然也待过一些群体，我们都很友好，喜欢聚在一起，
but we're not very productive. And so I think it's a common perception that we need to build teamwork and cohesion and build relationships as a foundation for productive teamwork. And that's not necessarily the case at least, not in our studies. So it's not about how people feel about each other. Where do you think the assumption comes from and why do you think it goes wrong?
但我们的生产力并不高。所以我认为这是一种普遍的看法，即我们需要建立团队合作和凝聚力，并建立关系作为高效团队合作的基础。这并不一定是事实，至少在我们的研究中不是这样。所以这与人们对彼此的感觉无关。你认为这种假设从何而来，为什么你认为它会出错？
If we've been on a team that worked really well together, often we have good feelings about that, good memories. Maybe they, it did involve people that we either liked at the time or came to like eventually. But the causation, the direction of causality is the part that I think is hard for us to always really detect. And in fact, that was one of the points that I heard early on in taking Richard Hackman's course that really struck me where he, I was going back through my notes recently and very early on, I had a lot of underlining in some of my assignments about, is it the fact that team members like each other
如果我们待过一个合作得很好的团队，我们通常会对那段经历有好的感觉、好的回忆。也许它确实涉及我们在当时喜欢或最终喜欢上的人。但因果关系，因果的方向是我认为我们很难总是真正察觉到的部分。事实上，那是我在理查德·哈克曼的课程中很早就听到的观点之一，它确实触动了我，我最近翻看我的笔记，在很早的时候，我在一些作业中画了很多下划线，关于：是因为团队成员彼此喜欢，
and that leads them to perform well or do they like each other because they performed well? And he was making the argument that it was more of the latter. In other words, you know, in sports teams, they sometimes say nothing brings a team together like winning. And in some ways, that's what you're talking about. When you're winning and things are going well, it's easy to feel like everyone, you know, is marching shoulder to shoulder. Exactly. And I, the problem is, if you then use that as a way to problem solve and to make the assumption that the way to make the teamwork together well is to get them to like each other, I think
从而导致他们表现良好，还是因为他们表现良好所以才彼此喜欢？他提出的论点是后者居多。换句话说，你知道，在运动队中，他们有时说没有什么比胜利更能让团队团结在一起了。在某些方面，这就是你在谈论的。当你获胜且事情进展顺利时，很容易感觉每个人，你知道，都在肩并肩前进。完全正确。而且，问题在于，如果你随后将其作为解决问题的方法，并假设让团队合作良好的方法是让他们彼此喜欢，我认为
that's the flaw in reasoning that sometimes is a problem. What's remarkable here is that we've looked at a number of different conclusions we might draw about why some teams are more effective than others? And it's actually kind of striking how often our intuitions are wrong, or at least not supported by the evidence. Well, teams, I think we're coming to understand are really complex adaptive systems. There are a lot of complex relationships
这就是推理中的缺陷，有时会成为一个问题。这里值得注意的是，我们审视了许多关于为什么有些团队比其他团队更有效的不同结论？令人震惊的是，我们的直觉经常是错误的，或者至少没有得到证据的支持。嗯，团队，我想我们开始理解它们确实是复杂的适应性系统。有很多复杂的关系
that are not linear. They're not direct one-to-one correlations. complex relationships that are not linear. They're not direct one-to-one correlations. There are a lot of things that work in combination and moderators and interactions and so on. And I think the human mind can't necessarily intuit all of that. And so we see the beginning and we see the end and maybe we assume there's a straight line in between
不是线性的。它们不是直接的一对一相关性。有很多东西在组合、调节和互动中起作用等等。我认为人类的大脑未必能直觉到所有这些。所以我们看到了开始，看到了结束，也许我们假设中间有一条直线，
when there isn't. Many people ex-told virtues of individual intelligence, feelings of camaraderie and cohesion, but these things do not always determine the effectiveness of the groups that Anita studied. When we come back, what does matter? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Anita Wolli studies the science of teamwork. Over many years of research, she's found that the things we commonly associate with great
而事实并非如此。许多人推崇个人智力、同志情谊和凝聚力的美德，但这些东西并不总是决定安妮塔所研究的群体的有效性。稍后回来，什么才是重要的？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家安妮塔·伍利研究团队合作的科学。经过多年的研究，她发现我们通常与优秀
teams, individual intelligence, a feeling of cohesion and camaraderie are not always good predictors of what makes for great teams. Anita, you have found three characteristics of great teams. The first of these has to do with a gender composition of teams. How did you come by this finding and what did you find? I feel like as we talk about this research, I keep saying, we didn't expect this and we didn't expect that. This is another one of those.
团队联系在一起的东西——个人智力、凝聚力和同志情谊的感觉——并不总是优秀团队的良好预测指标。安妮塔，你发现了优秀团队的三个特征。第一个与团队的性别构成有关。你是如何得出这个发现的，你发现了什么？我觉得当我们谈论这项研究时，我一直在说，我们没预料到这个，我们没预料到那个。这是另一个这样的例子。
We conducted a series of studies in our initial exploration of this whole collective intelligence hypothesis. A graduate student on the project noted a correlation with a proportion of women in the team and collective intelligence. And I was the one who initially said, oh, you know, I don't know. Let's see if that holds. Like, we shouldn't make a big deal about that until we know, you know, whether or not that's a really consistent pattern. and it was. And then as we dug into it more, we found that there were some other characteristics specifically of women that were really making a big part of the contribution to collective intelligence.
在我们对整个集体智力假设的初步探索中，我们进行了一系列研究。项目中的一名研究生注意到团队中女性比例与集体智力之间存在相关性。而我最初说，哦，你知道，我不知道。让我们看看这是否成立。就像，在我们知道这是否是一个真正一致的模式之前，我们不应该对此大惊小怪。结果确实如此。然后随着我们深入研究，我们发现女性确实还有一些其他特征，这些特征确实为集体智力做出了很大一部分贡献。
So if having more women on a team leads to high levels of collective intelligence, does this mean Anita that having teams entirely comprised of women are the best teams? Well, no. So as we've kind of gone on and accumulated more data, what we started to see really more clearly was a curvilinear effect, if you will, where teams that had majority female, but were still gender diverse, if you will, not entirely male or female, the teams that had majority women were most collectively intelligent. So the finding that having women on the team improves the outcomes of teams was connected to a perhaps larger phenomenon that you also observed, which is the capacity of teams to engage in social perceptiveness. What do you mean by that phrase on ETA and how would it work?
如果团队中女性成员更多能带来高水平的集体智慧，那么Anita，这是否意味着完全由女性组成的团队就是最好的团队呢？嗯，不是。随着我们不断积累数据，我们开始更清晰地看到一种曲线效应，如果可以这样说的话：那些女性占多数，但性别仍然多元——也就是说并非完全由男性或女性组成——的团队，其集体智慧水平最高。因此，团队中有女性能改善团队成果这一发现，与你观察到的另一个或许更大的现象有关，那就是团队进行社会感知的能力。你所说的“社会感知”是什么意思，它是如何运作的？
So social perceptiveness is really a capability that individuals possess to pick up on subtle cues and draw inferences about what others are thinking or feeling. And in teamwork, that can be really helpful because it also helps individuals anticipate how others might react and, you know, to kind of use that information to facilitate the communication and coordination of the group. And so somebody who is more socially perceptive might notice, okay, well, I'm talking too much. Maybe I should stop and let ask somebody else what they think. Or gee, we're not hearing from, you know, this other person. I wonder if they agree with what we're saying or if they have some points that they don't agree with.
社会感知实际上是个人捕捉微妙线索并推断他人想法或感受的能力。在团队合作中，这非常有帮助，因为它还能帮助个人预判他人的反应，并利用这些信息来促进团队的沟通与协调。因此，一个社会感知能力较强的人可能会注意到：“好吧，我说得太多了，也许我应该停下来问问别人的想法。”或者，“哎呀，我们还没听到这个人的意见，不知道他是否同意我们的说法，或者他是否有不同意见。”
You know, a whole variety of different tendencies that go along with social perceptiveness that also facilitate the collaboration of the group. So in some ways, I think what I'm hearing you say is that, you know, effective groups are groups that pay attention in some ways to one another. And perhaps the gender is sort of a marker of it, but it's only a, if you will, a crude marker of sort of what we're really trying to get at, which is that effective groups really are paying attention to one another and picking up on cues that people are sending
你知道，与社会感知相伴而生的各种倾向，也能促进团队的协作。在某种程度上，我想我听到的是，有效的团队是那些在某种程度上彼此关注的团队。也许性别只是一个标志，但它只是一个粗略的标志，我们真正想要探讨的是，有效的团队确实是在彼此关注，并捕捉他人发出的信号。
to different members of the group. That's right. So, the gender effect is really capturing that when you have individuals in a team who just have a habit of being attentive to the needs of other people, of responding, or anticipating what they might need, of maybe taking a step back and giving somebody else the floor and also stepping up to help when they see that somebody else needs help. All of those kinds of tendencies are things that foster collective intelligence in a group. The finding is mirrored by what Anita found when she explored how often individual spoke in group settings.
对团队中不同成员发出的信号。没错。所以，性别效应实际上捕捉到了这一点：当团队中的个人习惯于关注他人的需求，做出回应或预判他人的需求，也许会退后一步把发言机会留给别人，或者在看到别人需要帮助时挺身而出。所有这些倾向都是促进团队集体智慧的因素。这一发现与Anita在探索个人在团队环境中的发言频率时所发现的结果不谋而合。
Teams with higher levels of collective intelligence usually didn't have one person dominate the conversation. Yeah, so the consistent finding is that groups that are more collectively intelligent, they don't have the conversation dominated by one or a few people, you don't have all the work being done by one or a few people. There's roughly equal involvement in the group's collaboration. You've looked at how the user video platforms like Zoom
集体智慧水平较高的团队通常不会由一个人主导对话。是的，一致的发现是，集体智慧更高的团队，不会让对话被一个人或少数几个人主导，也不会让所有的工作都由一个人或少数几个人完成。团队协作中的参与度大致是平等的。你研究过像Zoom这样的视频平台如何
might affect the equality of team members' contributions. So what do you find? So we decided to just try using manipulation of whether or not the people collaborating could see each other on a video conference or just hear each other. And what we found was that the video conference actually seemed to reduce collective intelligence and one of the ways that it did that is it disrupted synchrony and sentiment. You know, if you're happy and I'm talking with you, my voice should reflect the happiness, you know, that you're communicating. And we tended to see that less when there was video in part because
影响团队成员贡献的平等性。那么你发现了什么？我们决定尝试操纵协作人员在视频会议中是否能看到对方，还是只能听到对方的声音。我们发现，视频会议似乎实际上降低了集体智慧，其中一个原因是它破坏了同步性和情感交流。你知道，如果你很高兴，而我正在和你交谈，我的声音应该反映出你所传达的快乐。我们倾向于在有视频时较少看到这一点，部分原因是
it really seemed like people were distracted, perhaps by the video, and also led to actually more unequal contribution to the conversation. There were certain people who were actually more likely to dominate the conversation when the conversation was taking place by video. A very interesting finding Anita has to do with the average level of social perceptiveness in the team. In another study led by some of your frequent collaborators, they looked specifically at the member of the team who scored lowest on social perceptiveness. Why did they do that and what did they find?
人们似乎确实被视频分散了注意力，这也导致了对对话的贡献更加不平等。当通过视频进行对话时，确实有某些人更容易主导对话。Anita的一个非常有趣的发现与团队中社会感知的平均水平有关。在由你的一些频繁合作者领导的另一项研究中，他们专门研究了团队中社会感知得分最低的成员。他们为什么要这样做，又发现了什么？
So what they found was that the lowest scoring member, if you will, was really the strongest predictor of the collective intelligence of the team. Because when you have somebody who is really not paying attention to these cues, the disruption that it creates can really offset all the benefits of what the others might be doing to try to facilitate collaboration.
他们发现，得分最低的成员实际上是团队集体智慧的最强预测指标。因为当你有一个人真的不注意这些线索时，它所造成的破坏可能会抵消其他人为促进协作所做的所有努力带来的好处。
And it echoes some other findings in the general research literature about bad apples, spoiling the barrel. When you have one person who is particularly problematic, the disruption it causes can really be some have a disproportionately negative effect on the team overall. I mean, I'm thinking about what happened to you
这呼应了通用研究文献中关于“一颗老鼠屎坏了一锅粥”的其他发现。当你有一个特别成问题的人时，他造成的破坏可能会对整个团队产生不成比例的负面影响。我在想你青少年时期在餐馆发生的事情。
in that restaurant when you were a teenager. And some ways having sort of one coworker who was really grouchy meant that, you know, other people simply stopped communicating with each other. That's right. And it could be that everybody else was perfectly capable of collaborating well or very, you know, competent
在某种程度上，有一个脾气暴躁的同事意味着其他人干脆停止了彼此沟通。没错。可能其他人完全有能力很好地协作，或者非常称职，
and we could have been a well-oiled machine. But as soon as we were, you know, withdrawing and not going to ask any questions or expose any mistakes, if we could possibly avoid it, that really cut off a lot of other possibilities for better performance. There's another kind of perceptiveness that matters to collective intelligence, and that is an awareness of what other people know and where to get the information that you need. This idea is sometimes called transactive memory, and it's a term coined by the late psychologist Daniel Wagner. Can you tell me about this idea Anita and how he came up with it? and Neil Wagner, can you tell me about this idea Anita and how he came up with it? Wagner initially noticed this in his own relationship
我们本可以成为一台运转良好的机器。但一旦我们开始退缩，不再提出任何问题或暴露任何错误（如果能避免的话），这确实切断了许多实现更好绩效的可能性。还有另一种对集体智慧至关重要的感知，那就是对他人的知识储备以及从何处获取所需信息的意识。这个概念有时被称为“交互记忆”，是由已故心理学家丹尼尔·韦格纳（Daniel Wegner）提出的术语。你能告诉我这个概念以及他是如何想到的吗？韦格纳最初是在他与妻子的关系中注意到这一点的，
with his wife where they recognized that there were a number of different areas of their relationship or even their shared experience where they would sort of specialize in remembering different details. And so whether it was about how to take care of different household things or even in recounting events, you know, that they had experienced together. They would each, you know, remember certain details and together they had quite a complete story, but it inspired him. He first looked at this and in other close couples and but then over time others have generalized these ideas
他们认识到在他们的关系甚至共同经历中，有许多不同的领域，他们会专门负责记住不同的细节。无论是关于如何处理各种家务，还是在讲述他们共同经历的事件时，他们每个人都会记住某些细节，合在一起，他们就拥有了一个相当完整的故事，但这启发了他。他首先在其他亲密伴侣身上观察到了这一点，但随着时间的推移，其他人将这些想法推广开来，
and looked at them in teams and other settings and found very similar patterns. The more effective teams, even outside of awareness, they don't necessarily know they're doing this, just like the married couples don't necessarily explicitly know, but they would fall into a pattern of coordinating and really
并在团队和其他环境中进行了观察，发现了非常相似的模式。更有效的团队，即使在没有意识到的情况下——他们不一定知道自己在这样做，就像已婚夫妇不一定明确知道一样——也会陷入一种协调的模式，并真正
expand the total amount of information they could collectively manage. I understand that one of your colleagues at Carnegie Mellon has found a robust transactive memory system among doctors is associated with better outcomes for their patients. Can you tell me about that work? Yeah, so Linda Argoady, who's one of my colleagues at the Tepper School at Carnegie Mellon, was looking at doctors working in trauma units and their work together in the implications for their patients. And what she found was that keeping the same members together
扩大他们集体能够管理的全部信息量。我了解到你在卡内基梅隆大学的一位同事发现，医生之间稳健的交互记忆系统与患者更好的预后相关。你能谈谈那项工作吗？是的，琳达·阿戈阿迪（Linda Argote），我在卡内基梅隆大学泰珀商学院的同事之一，她研究了创伤病房的医生以及他们的合作对患者的影响。她发现，保持成员稳定
helped them form a transactive memory system where they would specialize if you will in small ways, sometimes imperceptible ways, to focus on different details of the patient's care, and the patients who were being treated by teams that developed these more effective transactive memory systems actually had better outcomes. They were in the hospital for a shorter time. They were discharged more quickly, which is an important marker of the quality of care they've received. It was an important insight for thinking about how even medical teams can be affected by these very kind of subtle effects. I'm wondering what the idea of transactive memory means for
有助于他们形成交互记忆系统，他们会以微小的方式，有时是难以察觉的方式进行分工，专注于患者护理的不同细节。而由这些发展出更有效交互记忆系统的团队所治疗的患者，实际上预后更好。他们在医院的时间更短，出院更快，这是他们所接受护理质量的一个重要标志。对于思考医疗团队如何受到这些微妙影响，这是一个重要的见解。我想知道交互记忆的概念对于
the common belief that fresh blood is often good on teams. So you and I are members of a team. We work well together for long periods of time. But you know, one of us leaves and now a new person comes in and joins the team. What's the effect of this? What's the effect of turnover versus stability on the long-term success of teams? This is something that has been debated for quite some time. In fact, there was some research and R&D teams done in the 1980s, showing that teams that were together at that time
“新鲜血液对团队有益”这一普遍信念意味着什么。你和我是一个团队的成员。我们长期合作得很好。但你知道，其中一个人离开了，现在一个新人加入团队。这有什么影响？人员流动与稳定性对团队长期成功的影响是什么？这是一个争论已久的话题。事实上，20世纪80年代对研发团队进行的一些研究表明，当时在一起工作的团队
up to five years would continue to improve in terms of the quality of their outcomes and their communications, at least that long before you would see this kind of drop-off, where things might get stale, where they fall into routines, they don't recognize that they're using sort of outdated approaches. And so while bringing in somebody new can certainly bring in a new perspective or enable a team to consider some additional ways of addressing problems, teams also benefit from being
长达五年，在成果质量和沟通方面会持续改善，至少在出现这种下滑之前是这样，即事情可能会变得陈旧，他们陷入常规，没有意识到他们正在使用过时的做法。因此，虽然引入新人当然可以带来新的视角，或使团队能够考虑解决问题的额外方法，但团队也受益于
together for a good period of time so that they can learn how to work together so that they can learn how to work together, so that they can develop these shared systems for organizing and coordinating such as a transactive memory system, especially actually when we're learning something new. When we learn something new in a team, there's a lot about learning how to do it together that is important. And when we then change members, we really disrupt that process.
在一起工作一段较长的时间，这样他们才能学会如何一起工作，这样他们才能发展出这些用于组织和协调的共享系统，比如交互记忆系统，尤其是在我们学习新事物时。当我们在团队中学习新事物时，关于如何一起完成它的学习过程非常重要。而当我们随后更换成员时，我们确实破坏了那个过程。
And so other research and hospitals, Amy Edmondson has looked at surgical teams and how keeping them together, especially as they're learning a new procedure can be important. And that when you change the membership of the team too often, and in fact, most organizations create changes in teams very often, you really disrupt a lot of these processes
因此，医院里的其他研究，艾米·埃德蒙森（Amy Edmondson）研究了手术团队，以及保持团队稳定，特别是在他们学习新程序时，是多么重要。当你太频繁地改变团队成员时——事实上，大多数组织非常频繁地创建团队变更——你确实破坏了许多
that could otherwise be very beneficial. I mean, what I'm getting from this conversation really is the complexity of how teams come together and what makes them work. And I like the analogy you raised earlier about a team as being the equivalent of a single human brain which has different sections and regions that each do different kinds of things. And if you use that analogy, it's easy to see, taking out the limbic system, for example,
本可以非常有益的过程。我的意思是，从这次谈话中我真正感受到的是团队如何组建以及是什么让他们发挥作用的复杂性。我喜欢你之前提出的类比，即团队相当于一个拥有不同部分和区域的人类大脑，每个部分和区域都做不同类型的事情。如果使用这个类比，很容易看出，例如，移除边缘系统，
might not result in a brain that suddenly does very well because it's actually connected to all kinds of things that other parts of the brain are doing. Exactly. And so if I decided, oh, you know, I wish I had a better memory. And so I want to transplant this other memory, you know, that is objectively a better memory into my brain. I don't think we would expect it to work well with the other parts of my brain, you know, and seamlessly. All of a sudden I have this better brain. In essence, yes, I think the analogy with teams can be useful. I mean, in some ways, I think the arrow we make in teams is thinking about the team as being modular as basically the sum of its parts, whereas what I think you're really pointing at here
可能不会产生一个突然表现很好的大脑，因为它实际上与大脑其他部分正在做的所有事情都相连。完全正确。所以如果我决定，“哦，你知道，我希望我有更好的记忆力。所以我想把这个客观上更好的记忆移植到我的大脑中。”我不认为我们会期望它能与其他大脑部分无缝协作。突然之间我就有了这个更好的大脑。本质上，是的，我认为与团队的类比是有用的。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我认为我们在团队中犯的错误是把团队看作是模块化的，基本上是其各部分的总和，而我认为你在这里真正指出的是
throughout this conversation is that the team is really more than the sum of its parts, and swapping parts in, swapping parts out or the parts don't talk to one another, it can really affect how the collective performs. Absolutely. And so the collective intelligence really is produced from the coordination and collaboration of the parts. And so it's not plug-and-play for those parts.
在整个谈话中，团队确实不仅仅是各部分的总和，更换零件、拆除零件，或者零件之间不沟通，确实会影响集体的表现。绝对是这样。因此，集体智慧确实是由各部分的协调和协作产生的。所以这些部分不是“即插即用”的。
And necessarily, there's a fair amount of learning that goes into finding those processes and finding out what works. I mean, in some ways, I feel like the ideas that you're talking about are really applicable at almost every level, whether they're personal or professional or the level of communities or nations, which is, you know, how do you collaborate with other people? How do you get to work? Well, with other people, how do you have, you know, how do you actually get to share information back and forth in a way that would be helpful to other people? Absolutely. And I think a lot of it, I mean, just over and
必然地，找到这些流程并找出什么有效需要大量的学习。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我觉得你谈论的想法在几乎每个层面上都是适用的，无论是个人、专业，还是社区或国家的层面，即：你如何与他人协作？你如何才能工作得好？与他人一起，你如何真正以对他人有帮助的方式来回分享信息？绝对是这样。而且我认为很多时候，我的意思是，一遍又一遍地，
over again, you see the importance of not only people showing up with their skills and capabilities, but respecting and valuing the capabilities of the other people in such a way that both they will let themselves rely on them, as well as admit to where they could use some help. And I think the other way that it shows up all over the place is also being willing to ask questions and just clarify, you know, what are we doing? Why are we doing it? Because I think even in some of the big historical examples of failure, if somebody had spoken up and sort of just said, okay, hang on a minute, like what are we trying to do? What do we think we're going to accomplish? Is this really the best way to accomplish that?
你看到不仅是人们带着他们的技能和能力出现的重要性，而且是尊重和重视其他人的能力，以至于他们既会让自己依赖他们，也会承认自己在哪里需要帮助。我认为它在各处体现的另一种方式也是愿意提出问题并澄清：“我们在做什么？我们为什么要这样做？”因为我认为即使在一些重大的历史失败案例中，如果有人站出来说：“好吧，等一下，我们到底想做什么？我们认为我们要完成什么？这真的是完成它的最好方法吗？”
It might have caused people to rethink some assumptions they had about what they were trying to do or how it would work. And so I think over and over again we see in the collectively intelligent groups that you have people who are willing to do that. Anita Williams-Willey is a psychologist at Carnegie Mellon University. Anita, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy
这可能会促使人们重新思考他们关于自己想做什么或它将如何运作的一些假设。所以我认为一遍又一遍地，我们在集体智慧的群体中看到人们愿意这样做。Anita Williams-Woolley是卡内基梅隆大学的心理学家。Anita，感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain节目。谢谢你的邀请。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy
Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anzang Hero, we bring you a story from our sister's show, My Anzang Hero. It comes from Lidy Clots. My high school had always gotten crushed in soccer by the West Hill Warriors. We saw them as the rich kids from the city. One of their fathers took work calls on the sideline on the first mobile phone I ever saw. But my group of friends lived for soccer and we had supportive parents too.
Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。对于今天的“我的英雄”，我们为你带来一个来自我们姐妹节目《我的英雄》的故事。它来自Lidy Clots。我的高中足球队总是被West Hill勇士队碾压。我们把他们看作城里的富家子弟。他们的一个父亲在我见过的第一部手机上在边线处理工作电话。但我的朋友们为足球而活，我们也有支持我们的父母。
One of our parents parked a hay wagon on the sideline so that they could get elevated video footage of our games. And by the time we played West Hill my junior season, it was time for us to finally beat them. And I'll never forget, we're already ahead in this game, tut enough thing, when I drooled past my defender near the halfway line and made a backdoor pass to my friend who scored, which effectively ended the game. And I was so excited. As I ran to celebrate with my team,
我们的一位家长在边线停了一辆干草车，这样他们就能获得我们比赛的高空视频录像。到我高二赛季对阵West Hill时，是我们最终击败他们的时候了。我永远不会忘记，我们在比赛中已经领先了，当我运球越过中线附近的防守者，并向我的朋友传了一个后门球，他得分了，这有效地结束了比赛。我太兴奋了。当我跑去和我的团队庆祝时，
I screamed right in the face of West Hill's best player, a tall, blonde midfielder named Jeff Wentland. And Jeff was a big reason why we could never beat West Hill. He was skilled and smart and ultra competitive. I mean, he was the kind of guy who would slide tackle his grandmother to win. As soon as the final whistle blows for this game, Jeff makes a b-line right towards me, and my mind is racing for an excuse to justify why I had screamed in his face.
我对着West Hill最好的球员——一个名叫Jeff Wentland的高个子金发中场球员——的脸大喊大叫。Jeff是我们无法击败West Hill的一个重要原因。他技术娴熟、聪明且极具竞争力。我的意思是，他是那种为了赢球会铲倒自己祖母的人。比赛终场哨声一响，Jeff就径直朝我走来，我的大脑在飞速运转，寻找借口来证明我为什么对他大喊大叫。
But when Jeff got to me, he just shook my hand, congratulated me on the win, and invited me to join his club team. Now, this is a team that brought together the best players from all the high schools in our area. And top college coaches paid attention to that club team. Now, this is a team that brought together the best players from all the high schools in our area. And top college coaches paid attention to that club team. So playing on that club team put my development as a soccer player on a whole new trajectory. Jeff's invitation opened the door to the formative experiences of my young life,
但当Jeff走到我面前时，他只是和我握手，祝贺我获胜，并邀请我加入他的俱乐部球队。现在，这是一个汇集了我们地区所有高中最优秀球员的球队。顶尖大学教练会关注那支俱乐部球队。所以在那支俱乐部球队踢球让我作为一名足球运动员的发展走上了一个全新的轨道。Jeff的邀请为我年轻生活中形成性的经历打开了大门，
playing soccer, edit vision one college, and then for a couple years professionally. And in the decades since, I, not a soccer player anymore, but I thought a lot about that moment. Why didn't Jeff punch me in the face? Why didn't he just point out that despite my team beating his, he was still a better player than me, and he was? Why was Jeff so gracious?
踢足球，进入一级大学，然后职业踢球几年。在随后的几十年里，我不再是一名足球运动员，但我经常想起那一刻。为什么Jeff没有打我的脸？为什么他没有指出尽管我的球队击败了他的球队，但他仍然比我强（事实确实如此）？为什么Jeff如此大度？
Jeff was only in high school, but he already figured out one of the most important things about competition And that's that the game was over. He was looking ahead. I wasn't a trash talking rival anymore I was a potential teammate a partner Lidy Clots lives in Charlottesville, Virginia. Oh, and a club team that Jeff Wentland invited Lidy to join? It won the National Indoor Soccer Championship, their Senior Year of High School. You can find more of Anita Woolies' research and other resources on our website, www.HiddenBrain.org. While you're there, be sure to subscribe to our free newsletter.
Jeff当时只是个高中生，但他已经弄明白了关于竞争最重要的事情之一，那就是比赛已经结束了。他在向前看。我不再是一个说垃圾话的对手，我是一个潜在的队友，一个伙伴。Lidy Clots住在弗吉尼亚州的夏洛茨维尔。哦，Jeff Wentland邀请Lidy加入的那支俱乐部球队？它赢得了他们高中最后一年全国室内足球锦标赛的冠军。你可以在我们的网站www.HiddenBrain.org上找到更多Anita Woolley的研究和其他资源。在那里时，请务必订阅我们的免费通讯。
Every week we'll bring you the latest research on human behavior. Plus, we always include a brain teaser and a moment of joy. One last request. If you liked today's episode about teamwork, please share it with one or two people who you think would find it interesting. What if not suggestions are the best way to connect new listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain? I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每周我们都会为你带来关于人类行为的最新研究。此外，我们总是包含一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。最后一个请求。如果你喜欢今天关于团队合作的这一集，请分享给一两个你认为会感兴趣的人。如果不是建议，还有什么更好的方式将新听众与我们在Hidden Brain探索的想法联系起来呢？我是Shankar Vedantam，很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。